hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the Grantchester it's the
England versus Maxime Bashar Alegre
battling it out for first place and also
a prize of $150,000 which is the first
prize second prize is $100,000 so both
of them are very nice so if you've been
following the coverage so far you know
that ding had a very impressive game in
the game one of the classics and
mvl was able to draw the game with that
crazy Queen an opponent game which
turned into a for Queens end game and
then ding had nothing more than a draw
but in the second game of the classics
ding was able to take him wheel down
with the white pieces so here this is
the first game of the rapids I do hope
you enjoy it let's check it out so with
the white pieces ding opens with d4 we
have Knight to f6 by magazine c4 and g6
and g3 now so again the the Kings Indian
defense we have c5 Knight to f3 and
Bishop to g7 with Bishop to G to Maxine
castles and now d5 so basically
basically going for sort of a benoni
setup we have d6 Knight to c3 and now e
6 with castles and now with this
character's cappers we basically do get
a benoni benoni defense we've looked yet
by maksim and rook to e1 preparing efore
we have Bishop to f5 and now comes
Knight to d2 which is often the case in
the benoni you make room for a4 and also
make room for this night to come to c4
from where you will harass the d6 pawn
also Bishop therefore is an idea so you
can also help out with the harassment of
the d6 pawn and black will have to
resort to some not so enjoyable moves
like Bishop to f8 to help out with the
defense so here there is one game where
Quintus c8 was played in the database
but tonight the a6 is a new move by
Maxine and it is no wonder Maxime or
very often puts his knight on the edge
of the board so it is as of move 11 that
we have a completely new game we have EC
for biding pushing the bishop back
Bishop g4 attacking the Queen and now f3
just pushing the bishop even further
back Bishop to d7 and now nice to see
for nd you if you've ever played the
Benoni you
that it can be quite troublesome to
figure out what well what to do with
your light square bishop with Queen to
b8 now defending the d6 pawn and now
just brush up to a4 piling up on that d6
pawn bishop to f8 now defending the d6
pawn and a for grabbing more space on
the Queen side not allowing b5 but also
now doing no longer has control of the
before square so anvil gets the knight
in there so Knight to be four perhaps he
can somehow get the night all the way to
b3 if possible sometimes in the future
Queen to d2 just connecting rooks
preparing to grab more space on the King
side with Knight to h5 attacking the
bishop on f4 it's a very important piece
so of course in Vale wants to eliminate
it Bishop to g5 and now f6 pushing the
bishop even further back and ding is not
interested in trading at so he just goes
back Bishop to e3 we have F 5 by Maxine
it's a committal move but there there
are no better moves you don't really
have good ideas for the for the night
you the roof doesn't really have
anything to do the bishop has no squares
you don't really have a good way of
developing the Queen the rook is stuck
here so you have to do something so he
goes for f5 e capture some a5 Bishop
captures an i5 dis now freezes
LightSquared Bishop and now g4 it
doesn't win a piece since Maxine has
Bishop to d3 of course now you attack
the knight the undefended piece on c4
with Bishop to f1 by dink Bishop
captures King captures and now the
knight just goes back Knight to f6 and
here Bishop to g5 biting and already we
have a very interesting position where
black has to decide how to react to this
night being attacked so one way you
could do it is just by it for example
King to g7 as you still have to keep an
eye on the under d6 pawn but if King to
g7 this just loses completely to Bishop
captures on f6 King captures now you
just trade once a rogue capture screen
captures and now you deliver the Knight
to e4 check now it doesn't really matter
what what the King does if you go to f7
then you just capture on d6 even if
Bishop captures the other night then
characters on b6 Forks the king and the
Queen and you lose the Queen
so you have to go somewhere like King g7
but now Queen c3 check and again if you
go here then this one's the Queen if you
go let's say to g8 then this one's the
Queen and if you go to h6 then you're
getting made it after g5 King here and
the Quinta well sorry and f4 freeing the
h3 square for the Queen Queen to h3 is
the threat of checkmate now and there is
no way around it you could try Queen d7
to guard it but then again you lose the
knight to f6 check for King the king and
the Queen even though you're not
interested in winning the Queen you just
want to deliver mate so Queen the g3
will be made so that's one way to do it
after Bishop g5 King g7 is not not gonna
work another way you could do it is by
moving the knight 97 but still adding
gets a beautiful rook lift a to rook to
e6 and now you just wait and wait and
just lose for example if the other row
comes to e1 is just all over so here you
could trade captures captures but then
after Knight moves to b6 you'll just
capture it and push the pawn all the way
and that's just it Knight moves Knight
comes to b5 and you will bring this rook
over to e1 where you will support the
advancement of the pond the night can
come to C 7 or D 6 to also help out with
with watching the queening square and
that's that's that's the game
so after Bishop to g5 we have Bishop to
g7 MBL says okay I'm gonna retreat one
of the defenders of the d6 square but
now Dean uses a beautiful triangulation
Bishop to f4 so this is much better the
bishop came from e3 to g5 n into F or if
you just went to f4 wouldn't be a
problem because it seems the bishop
would be an FA this way it now comes to
f4 again with a double attack here and
now maxime could go back back up to f8
but now it's it's just like ding wanna
move because dings bishop was here
nothing's Bishop is here and also it's
things move once again so here he would
just go look to e6 and again threatened
rook a to e1 have a very very very easy
game so maxime decides to sacrifice the
d6 pawn for activity he plays Queen to
d8 and okay ding captures at whim Knight
captures on d6 rook to
fate in the now King to g2 just getting
the king guard wait so once the Queen
enters the game you don't have to worry
about something like Knights the d3
check and so on and also it's just a
safer Square for the King with Queen to
d7 now maybe with ideas of Knight
characters on g4
I followed by Queen captures on g4 also
the rook is on a nice semi open file
soon to open up so first bishop the g3
just the additional protection for Dinks
king and now Maxime goes for h5 we have
g5 pushing the knight back nights the
ei8 attacking the knight but now rook
the e6 finally the rook reaches the
destination with h4 attacking the bishop
but just Bishop to f4 it's not a problem
and here h3 with check which ding
ignores ding doesn't want to capture if
you capture then you align the king with
the Queen and then all sorts of tactics
come to mind like Knight captures on d5
just eliminating the defender or the
rook and even if you play Queen captures
and defend the room just 97 with a
double attack and white just falls apart
here so of course the ink is not
interest if he plays came to g3 and now
Knight captures on d6 finally yeah weird
rush of characters on d6 and rook to f5
now preparing to bring the other work
into the game
yeah but rook 81 ding of course brings
the other look into the game as well and
now you're there are so many ideas here
you can you can capture the c5 pawn you
can capture the g6 point you can go rook
to e7 there there are just so many ideas
and it's hard to defend against all of
them so here yeah Maxime decides to
trade a few pieces he goes Bishop to f8
but ding now doesn't mind he he just
goes rook captures and g6 with Chuck
came to h7 and now he brings the other
look to the 6th rank so what do you do
here rook to e8 now Maxime wants to
trade trade more pieces and get the
final rook into the game but the thing
is already up 2 points so it's not a
problem for him Bishop captures on f8
rook captures on e6 we have route
captures on e6 and rook captures and I
fade and here ding just played f4 and
well it was in this position unmoved 39
that Maxim for shield agrees
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here yeah yes he is only done two
points but the threat of queenie -
followed by Queen to h5 check
there's no no defending that you can't
really prevent that if Queen to have
seven just geez g6 check wins the Queen
if Queen g7 you still don't stop
anything just Queen e2 again there's no
defending this position Queen to h5 is
coming you could move the King but still
Queen h5 there is no defense against the
rook to g6 so it's completely over
so after f4 maxime resigned the game and
that's another victory for ding in this
tournament and I believe ding-ding has
not lost a single game so far in the
Grantchester in in the Grantchester
final so that's really really awesome
for him and his rating and well I'm now
going to mention it since dink was up 6
points now he won't for more points and
he only needs a draw to win the grand
chester title the second game of the
rapids has been played and the maxim was
unable to take him down with the white
pieces
ding was able to draw that game and so
ding is the official Grantchester 2019
winner
so dink wins that well dings murder wins
the 150,000 dollars maxine gets a
hundred thousand dollars which which is
great and really impressive stuff with
dings now even though Magnus came into
the London chess classic the
Grantchester finals as the huge favorite
and he had a lot more points than
everyone else here it's it was all ding
ding just obliterated everyone and it
was just really really impressive chef
that's that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it
we're gonna check up check out a few
more games from the Grantchester finals
of course we do have to check up on
Magnus and Levin and there are four more
blitz games to be played which is
something that if you've seen the quote
above the board says not so exciting
biding Liron Maurice asking how does he
feel now that he won the grand chester
finals and after everything is over and
i don't know if he wanted to say that or
or maybe he meant something else he just
said not so if
citing that he said there are four more
blitz games to play so you know he still
needs to be focused it's and it's not
over even though he won the grand
Chester and the 150 thousand dollars but
that's just Dean you know he has no
weaknesses he is the perfect warrior so
we'll see what happens next
like I said we're gonna check up a few
more games I would like to thank Randy
raveling Paul Gauguin Braxton Reynolds
and one min Gentile virus for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - my previous video serum
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the
Grantchester finals checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and of course
continuing our with our next big saga so
thank you I will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your Sunday